back in the 1980s powerless distributing
processing books came out they had most
of the stuff in it back then what's your
take on the roadblocks the most
important roadblocks apart from maybe
funding I think fundamentally I mean
they're they're well known as
limitations is that they're really
inefficient at learning and they're not
so they're really good at extracting
representations from raw data but not
good at learning knowledge bases of like
accumulating knowledge over time that
that's the fundamental limitation i
expert systems are really good at
accumulating knowledge but very bad at
doing that in an automated way symbolic
AI so I don't know how to overcome a lot
of people say there's hybrid approaches
I believe more data bigger networks and
better selection of data will take us a
lot farther
you